[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we won
anthony lee is back
but at this point it's not even a big
surprise anymore
just that introduce him we're called at
the anthony
again the kazoo oh
how's it going do you have do you have
your talk box i wish i had attack box i
need to get that
right box but i got this
[Music]
do you get old saliva in that like do
you ever like inhale and it's like old
breath
oh god do you clean it what
like cleaning are you crazy everybody's
just scrutinizing his toy now he uses
that like
people use a barbecue grill oh yeah for
the seasoning yeah he leaves it seasoned
my musicianship gets better with more
dust
i don't think we're i don't think we're
worried about dust
it's the layers of different saliva
different states of saliva like after
you eat
after you brush your teeth in the
morning yeah yeah
[Laughter]
uh i don't think what happens is it
dries out
so you forget that anything was ever
there then i yeah for sure
like it layers that's why i'm like do
you eventually get a flavor i think
that's how
it smells did you know that if you wrap
it around like this
it dries yeah it cleans it up oh you
play it like this then you suck it all
in
so you just tucked it all in i'm just
kidding
it's just my own lips i don't care it's
like sucking my own dick
nice have you tried that yeah have you
ever attempted
but i couldn't reach how close did you
get not even that close
so like well because one i'm not
flexible and two i don't have a big dick
try right now
try it let's just see how far we can you
have to
dude you're
closer you're way way closer how come
you can't do that
what he said he's like oh yeah he's way
closer than
he's like a he's got a good technique
going to put your arm around using the
opposition of his arms to his legs
gentlemen yo about you guys can we
i just feel how far am i where am i do i
need like a 14 inch dip
i can't do it we're a teenager that's
not too bad
it's got to go inside though how come
dogs collect their own
nuts god wanted them to that's why i'm
not flexible
i'm not maybe there's like a hidden
secret where going from the back side is
easier
damn that's kind of sexy because you
don't you don't know when it's going to
happen
that's kind of yoga isn't it i feel the
hot breath
surprise yourself good job guys yeah
thank you i didn't see nelson try
did you like yeah i tried i mean i tried
doing the one leg you take yoga lessons
are you could not even look at this i
can barely touch my knee
oh yeah i don't think i'm not flexible
either i can't touch my toes can you
guys i gotta
i gotta stretch more you're so close to
your dick though a little
too bad i'm not flexible anyway wasn't
there that huge marilyn manson thing
where he took out his ribs yeah is that
a real thing no i think
they found out it was like an urban
legend or something
during the show man that is a really
successful urban legend you were here
was i here you asked the same [ __ ] okay
i don't know but i remember like that
was the talk of the town
in elementary school it was wasn't it
yeah everyone wanted
an elementary school right oh i do think
so
yeah i don't really bring up marilyn
manson's like his own dick often
you do but when you think of dick
sucking that's what you think of man
yeah self dick suck yeah for sure yeah
he found this picture
and he sent it to the group and it was
so disturbing so it was this dude
who had both of his legs passed his head
and he was going to town on the fattest
dick i've ever seen
no his own dick right oh yeah his own
dick
i could picture it in my head and i
thought you guys could see what i saw
but yeah
like you were just going to town on his
own dick so he's like
oh i mean not that big but it was long i
mean it was probably girthy because it's
long
it was like two of these yeah oh my
goodness two yeah
two of those and he was stuck in it damn
it but it it does look funny though i
don't know
you could measure a penis by the ounce
and it's in a
and it's an accompanying group chat yes
it is
i think i it was in that one because
during that time there were so many
memes and like so many photoshop things
of
like dicks that i just stopped checking
the chat because i'm like
yeah the big black dude yeah yeah the
funny thing is during the whole
quarantine thing
that was the go-to meme for every like
everyone was using it follow uh tr
offroad truck accounts they would find a
way to embed that
inside the truck gun accounts fitness
it was across every industry for some
reason united as
did you see the the murder hornet meme
yeah
once murder awareness was a huge thing
this meme started getting passed around
and then it zooms into the murder
hornets actual freaking stinger and it's
the dudes
hell yeah i love people on the internet
or something yeah yeah that's sad
he did but his but his memory lives on
he died
no he didn't oh my goodness dang so the
most infamous dick out there right now
doesn't even know that he's why did why
did that always
i mean why did that come out the first
thing when quarantine started too
it was like the first week it was only
through that group chat that i ever
encountered no it was everywhere i
didn't
yeah everywhere damn i don't know
every news thing like even my friends
would send me now they're like
oh my god you're not gonna believe it uh
donald trump's gonna wage war against
russia
what i click on it it's like a big ass
dick in my face
we have different types of friends
because i have not i have not had a
black dick sent to me
but you're all good friends man damn
your friends are too immature man
but it's not it's not a random one it's
the buff guy
it's the guy yeah very very nice looking
face
they're not with the times big teddy
bear yeah super huge teddy bear
no hair up here just really nice smile
on a corner of a bed can't miss him yeah
yeah yeah and he's like in this like
position
yeah and it's just like wow
it's [ __ ] huge you know how like i
don't know how you guys feel but
when i'm in my normal day i don't even
feel that my dick is there
yeah my ears right like i don't know why
my ears are there until someone touches
it
i wonder if his dick is so big that
he just knows that it's there all the
time oh yeah huh
like well like your arm or something
yeah because you kind of know that your
arm's there like we
you know we can always forever always
always always see our own nose but we
just ignore it
oh yes like literally like right now you
can see your own
nose yeah i could see it no hang on i
can't see my nose
yeah you can no i can't i can't i swear
to god oh you can see the bridge
i got asian eyes we already got like
less surface area stupid
it's true oh you know what something
else though that's true so technically
your eyelashes are always in the way of
your sight but you just see past them
yes unless you wear falsies in my eyes
you know what that means that means look
past the [ __ ]
or it blocks you from the [ __ ] or it
probably means
um you should take notice of the things
that are always there
i don't know like the ones that are
right under your nose
i see it some people don't because
they'll have a booger hanging down and
they just don't notice nobody knows
you can't see under your nose that's
true i wish you could sing is a thing
i think there's a lot of things that are
right under your nose
that you don't notice like your lips and
your mouth like you're
the bottom of your chin do you guys ever
look under your chin yeah when i shave
yeah oh because you guys get to shave
yeah
but too when i shave i never notice it
until like i have something like
something
you gotta shave like i have some bumps
here and i was like oh [ __ ] i didn't
even realize i
i have like a whole world under here
what it's like the ocean
yeah that's under the ball sack for us
look at that yeah oh yeah behind the
ball sack i don't look back there i
always actually know what it looks like
there's new moles when it's the same one
and i get surprised each time
what on your boat like you go like
yeah i'm like ah it's a new it's a new
mole and i'm like oh wait wait wait no
no
orion star now that was there that was
there and i get surprised again
orion star like the whole belt is there
orion's belt
nice three of them you got a little
triple line yep
i got a couple constellations yep you
know recently i looked up uh
my because we're talking about
constellations which makes you think and
balls
casey's balls casey's balls well no i'm
actually going away from that
okay oh okay what did you guys see the
comment though yeah it was happening for
like the past month
yeah look at it cool i didn't know that
oh yeah i thought an indian girlfriend
done now you can't see anymore what do
you mean the past month like it keeps
going back and forth no i mean it takes
like a while
it's not like a shooting star where it
disappears it's in it's like far away
but you can see it with the tail behind
it and everything
yeah and it you can see for like two
three weeks with your naked bear
eyeballs
well i don't look like i put on glasses
because i can't see but
yeah you can just see it oh i missed it
damn dude you should have
you can't see naked eye in l.a you got
to go through way too much stuff
i went to like la canada and i just
looked at it see that's
when's the last time you guys went
outside and looked at the sky though
like every night almost every night we
appreciate
at night well no it's just because taika
likes looking at the moon
oh he goes outside moon yeah
yeah so he wants to see it at night yeah
that's adorable it's like sailor moon
we're gonna be seeing this guy more
often like pretty soon because our
backyard's almost done
gonna be hanging out there what's your
backyard look like now
our backyard is it just construction
right now um well it's not fully done
but they're they're almost done with
building the island
stuff and then you have an island in
your backyard
like a countertop thingy you know what i
mean and then like half of it is deck
and then the other half is like cement
and i'm gonna paint it is there gonna be
a
barbecue thingy yes there is there
currently is
but uh the landscaper is pretty cool
because he shout out to
you guys because you guys recommended
him to us but he
he knew like the laws and he was like
well you have to legally have this much
feet away from a standing building to
have a grill
like stationary there and so he's like
okay a loophole to this
is don't make your grill stationary so
just have like one jacket movable
pull into the counter and then we can
move the grill and then we're legal
you know what else i recommend a laundry
stain remover sponsored by
oxiclean that's good so they got this
new thing
called the oxiclean max force it comes
in both a spray
and a stick and if you get all kinds of
stains like me
whether it's because i'm training or
because i'm out hiking
and you get grass stains or you get
blood stains from like jiu jitsu or
whatever they're really hard to take out
how many especially if you have a white
thank you
especially if you have a white ghee it's
really hard to take that out so i like
using the spray and you spray it on you
let it soak and overnight and the next
day you throw in the laundry
and now all of your whites look good you
don't have to throw it away
and all of your grass stains come out so
i really really like it go check it out
and so if you got to try the oxiclean
max force for yourself to work your
magic with oxiclean go to oxiclean.com
maxforce1 to get a coupon for one
dollar off baby it's gonna be so nice
because
clean clothes make a clean human being
so much fun you know i joined our
neighbor watch neighborhood watch
you join the neighborhood watch you yes
you have to patrol or do you just yeah
how do you join that so it's actually
really organized um so our community was
just pretty cool like everyone's coming
together and we really care about
i guess just our community and we're
getting to know each other
so our last neighborhood neighborhood
watch meeting was yesterday do you think
she still got the same logo of that guy
with a big jacket and a hat
the guy who looks like a people i
haven't seen it but i just was talking
to him
it looks like a flasher huh yeah with
the with the two orange sides
yeah i hope they still have that let's
stuff
i uh i haven't seen that sign put up yet
but then i didn't want to join it so
i attended the zoo meeting and how it's
broken up
is there's a neighborhood watch
representative from the police
department cool
so that person's there to kind of hear
all the concerns and stuff
they live in the neighborhood no they
just work they work for the city
wait the neighborhood watch like
representative is
not a resident it's like an actual work
working position for the city
what i didn't know that anything well i
have a quick question is that person
assigned to each community or like
the city as a whole for each of them so
yeah so that person's assigned to the
city
in your community you have a community
like captain that's the resident
that's a volunteer like your block or
whatever yeah and then
per street in your community you have a
block captain so your block
captain reports to your main captain of
the community
and then this person reports to the
person actually works in the city
and now i see why like this whole
hall monitor karen personality trait
comes about because what the
neighborhood watch lady was saying is
there is
no warning or caution or issue
thing too small anything that has
happened someone steals a
freaking fruit a fruit or a clothespin
off your laundry yeah get those
you want to talk about it every month
and report it because whichever
community
has uh more issues they report that to
the police department and that's where
that part of the city gets more patrol
wow so i guess so can you go
neighborhood watch
citizens arrest that i don't know i
always wanted to do that i wanted a
badge that says neighborhood watch and
go neighborhood watch
wait they've give badges or did you make
that up you make it on my own oh yeah
very deuteronomy
trophies i'll be like neighborhood watch
i'm putting you under citizens alright
yes
i have my ibs card don't mix it up
though dude because they
read it they're not going to stop
they'll just be like that ain't it
yeah that's just the poo poo sign so you
need to take a [ __ ]
right now i'm trying to steal this out
like around this house i'ma steal the
whole house yeah
but i also have a siren too
it's a saucer flies
i would hear that [ __ ] every night
imagine there's a crime happening but
he's like
i gotta get it right nope
nope that's the right one he's just next
to car alarms just training for hours
he's learning from the masters
[Laughter]
we've got that hair too sensei
[Laughter]
man that sounds fun but also kind of
like a headache
the neighborhood watching yeah sounds
funny it sounds cool so what the part
that i like about it is
we are voicing to each other like what
we've seen that are kind of weird in the
community oh have you seen that weird
car that comes in parking the guy that
always
comes and you have a photo that guy's in
jail now which is awesome
that's so helpful the one with the photo
that you took my neighborhood watch
person that works for the city
they came and they're like hey guys i
want to give you an update on that
person
uh avery and then they're like this guy
is in jail now
and i'm like oh [ __ ] what that's tight
so that's right
he's in jail for 52 months well it's a
long time he's committed so many crimes
and not only our city but the
neighboring cities
yeah so so there's enough crime that's
happening where they
at first he was going to county but now
it's elevated to the state level
because he's committing crimes in so
many different places so everyone is
kind of prosecuting at the same time
it sucks that it takes that long though
to get somebody
off the streets yeah it takes a long
time yeah
it's kind of like you have to wait till
they rob
kill steal rape and then they get it's
like
i mean yeah but i also learned other
things about the city where i found out
our city has a like homeless and
transient
uh housing fund so what they're saying
is like don't feel bad
calling the dispatch if you do see like
a homeless person
because they will take them to where
there is appropriated housing for them
oh nice so it's like they because they
people don't want like
unwanted strangers or whatever like if
you have your kids playing you just
don't want any random people you don't
know so they're like just report
everything
and we will figure out the right things
to do to sort everything out
reporting directly to the police
department or to your captain
to the number on the website so you can
go on the city website and you just look
up
uh dispatch and you just call that
number and you go hey there's like this
weird person that's playing the snickers
bar like a trombone can you please
come and pick it up and then if it's
after the fact then we'll submit it to
the captain but i think when it's
happening in the moment or it's like
still fresh i think so they can handle
it right away you're gonna get a call
and be like
there's a random guy in our neighborhood
playing the sneaker of his bar like a
trombone and he has a snake in his hair
and it's like tied up weird oh no no
that's
yeah they're just like is it joe yeah
yeah it's cool
just like is it avery oh yeah we know
and what's nuts
like during growing up like you know you
never want to be a rat right like that's
like the last thing yeah you don't want
to call it you don't want to ever
you don't want to rat or anything but
then now as i get older when i hold from
the lady they're like the last thing
that you want
is your neighbor's house getting broken
into because no one ratted and then the
detective comes
and then asks you and then you saw
someone go into their house and they're
like the detective goes
hey did you see any weird people
yesterday yeah and then you're like
oh far i could have stopped that so i'm
like i see why people
are hall monitors now do you feel like
some of the captains of the neighborhood
get the the power in their head they're
like i'm the captain
could be i am the captain now i can see
that but so far everyone in our
neighborhood is pretty nice
but don't you like don't you kind of
like karen's though
[ __ ] yeah when it doesn't affect when
they're on your team they're on your
side
[ __ ] yeah i'll be at like some
restaurants or something right
and like starbucks or whatever and you
do see them [ __ ] around and then
you're like waiting
some restaurants
when you're waiting in line
[Laughter]
he's like so does everyone else in this
life
but you can always count on a karen as
soon as it takes more than two minutes
excuse me we've been waiting here and
you're just like [ __ ] yeah dude say
something man
oh yeah yeah but at the same time you're
like i would never do that
i don't but then but then you're kind of
glad though cause you're like i was
actually in a [ __ ] hurry too i was
just i couldn't say that
differentiation between that kind of
karen and then the racist carrying cause
those are the karen's are like okay
you're annoying
yeah but you actually kind of do that
that's good karen that's good karen the
spider-man of karen and there's the
venom
good or convenient i think there's a
difference on that one
it's like convenient karen with a k
convenient
you know what i mean
[Music]
do
i